Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Shadows 2.
Now, I hope to finish the game
and I'm hoping that this works.
Everybody cross your fingers!
(Manly man scream)
I think we're there.
I think this is where we left off, right? Floor 6?
Okay, so I'm gonna try to get through all the floors,
uh, right now--immediately
--and HOPEFULLY
I can get to the bottom of the mystery
of this whole office, and why we're here,
of which I do not know.
Hello?
Anybody in the bathroom?
Ooh, hello.
Well, that's a new decoration on mah bed.
Why did I take that?!
Why did I need a skull?!
Why do I bring skull? Did I put it in my pants?
Do I have skull pants?
Uh...
Hello.
No mannequins in here? No more reflection in here?
Ooh.
Hey...
You're new.
You weren't there before.
I would've remembered.
Tube of toothpaste?
Not a key?
Alright...
So you're just following me around wherever I go.
*Impersonates* Hi...
*Giggles* Exactly what I would say.
Oh, I can't move.
Oh, there we go.
*Impersonates again* Hi...
Alright-y, then.
Everything seems fine.
Goodbye, have love-ly day.
Ooh, hello.
"A key to success is.. head."
Oh!
I get it!
*Chuckles*
--Oh...*Realization*
Why?! *Giggles*
That do--What?!
Oh, okay.
Y'know what? I'm not gonna question it.
I'm gonna accept everything that I see in this game
as a--
-the utmost sure thing of reality.
And everythi--
Ooh...
Hey.
Hi...
You had a note!
You took it away from me again!
Another goddamn note went missing!
Hey, I'm not gonna follow you.
I'm gonna go the counter way.
Never mind!
There nothin' over here!
Alright, I'm comin' for ya!
I'm gon' STRANGLE ya!
Even though you don't have a head.
"I'm already here."
Oh, hi.
Uh,
cool?
Ha--
--Do--
*Mark starts walking*
You hear that? (Yes Mark, we heard you walking you dumb dumb)
No?
*Mark starts walking again*
Eeh...
Okay.
*Loud slamming* Fuck off!
"I should hide somewhere before it opens the door."
What do you mean?!
*Completely "manly" scream*
I don't know where to hide!
Closet!
Bathroom, hide in the bathroom!
*Screams* Goddammit!
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die!
♪ Oh, I can't find anywhere to hide ♪
♪ I'm an idiot! ♪
I'm a fuckin' idiot.
Oh, God.
What?
Huh?
*Ghostly moaning*
Uh, oh.
*Moaning continues*
Ooh, eh.
Ah!
*Moaning loudens*
I didn't do nothin'!
I may have taken a skull and put it 'nto my pants
and disrespected the dead!
And I may have flirted with a few too many mannequins
in my life.
But that doesn't mean that I deserve this,
whatever's happening.
Whatever it may be.
Whatever you may be lookin' at.
Okay.
Alright-y
--ooh, hey, secret!
Cool!
got a secret
Got a secret!
That's always good.
that's always good glad I got that right
Glad I got that.
*Bye have a beautiful time*
What?
Was that a couch?
Did a
--Did a couch just dive as quickly as it could?
Huh!
Alright-y, then.
Oh, no, it was a table.
*Mark gasps* *loud noise followed by a scream*
*Wheezes* Okay...
Okay.
Caught my breath, there, pretty good.
That's okay.
"I think it's gone by now."
What?
You think what's gone by now?
I dunno what you're talkin' about
I don't know what you're talking about
get out of my way yeah you really better
--get outta my way.
*Mark threatens Mannequin* Yeah, ru (you) ru better back off
back off
Alright, so what was that all about?
Heh, huh?
Note.
"I barley survived this time
that thing was so close to me ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
One move and I could be dead. Let's keep moving."
*Chuckles*
"One move and I could be dead.
Better keep movin', then!
Huh.
There's no way to go but forward."
This guy's br--
*Notices his worst enemy*
... what?
Alright-y, then.
They need to chill with the goddamn mannequins,
because I'm not havin' NONE of this.
Hello.
Ooh...
*Serial killer Mark returns* ♪ Come out, come out, wherever you are! ♪
*Loud slam*
*Gasp*
Oh.
♪ Note in the toilet! ♪
"Death is a common behavior.
You can't escape from it. It's already here
-Or there-
--It's there already.
Face it. You can try to avoid it, but you'll fail soon enough."
*Breath*
Hi.
Should I stick that skull in my pants?
Oh, is this what this metaphor was alluding to...
...all along?
Ho, ho, ho!
Well, dive right in!
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
It was good, I enjoyed it.
Have love-ly day.
Oh.
Oh good.
(Drug trips starts)
(manly scream)
what is happening!? oh god ( remember kids, don't do drugs )
Hello.
Well, my vision went perturbed.
"My FACKIN' (fucking) brain.
Something interrupts it badly.
I need to find some meds somewhere."
yeah probably a good idea you know the
med storage in your local office that --
--ooh.
(Quiet) What the fuck is that?
Who the fuck are you?
who da fuck? woah what's with your head? *slightly louder* oh what's with your head?
Hi.
"This isn't real."
How do you know?
You don't know that isn't real.
I mean, my God.
You wanna look at me?
Actually, don't look at me.
Never mind.
Don't do that.
I'm just go I'm gonna go now I'm gonna
go now
Doesn't work.
That's great.
That's comforting.
so I need to find- ooh that's right there
was a medicine cabinet over here for some...
frickin reason
Meds?
(Drug trip ends)
Did I get some?
Good!
Everything's better, now.
Everything's hunky d-dory.
oh and good this is working now
good!
Great!
A'ight. Down we go,
I suppose.
I bet I missed some secrets
here and there. Man we got a lot of floors
left to go but I'm hoping to conquer
them all- a buh-da-buh-buh! who's right
Who's writin'?
"Every step I'm closer to the exit.
I'm half the way, now.
Still wonder if anyone's alive left besides me..."
alive left besides me
No one in the whooole wide world.
No one at all
Who else is here?
well what the hell who rearranged my
furrrniture
(Quiet) Anybody in the bathroom?
(Serial Killer Mark returns) ♪ Come out, come out! -
"Bathroom -- Office Room." What? Bathroom office room?
I think you're confused.
I'm pretty sure you don't know what you're talking about.
"Bathroom--Office Room"
What does that mean?
Bathroom to office room, am I supposed to go
from one to the other?
"What? I had a phone like this 5 minutes ago, what is it doing here?"
Well, I don't know.
Eh...
I don't know...
"15."
"Bathroom - Office Room," "15."
This makes sense?
Question mark?
Are you guys able to make any sense out of this?
Oh,
hi,
how's it goin'?
Alright -- I don't even bother to say hi to those.
"I LOVE YOUR BUTT."
Whoa, oh, no, you do not!
Oh, the Crazed Butt-stabber!
(Battle cry)
Oh. (Disappointed Markimoo)
I--heh--
--Why do you love my butt?
Wha-- Why do you--
Why?
Why do you love
--Ooh.
I--I love your butt? (Question mark?)
Should I...
Am I supposed to look deep into this butt crack?
huh all right fine then okay
Huh?
Alright.
Fine, then,
okay.
You love mah butt.
Pretty sure plenty of people do.
"32."
"15," "32."
Is that a--
Is that a super secret code that I need?
office room
15:32 I don't know that
(the rest of the captions from here on are poorly done)ok 15:32 link Ron code
wrong code to a child wrong code come on
oh here we go 26 I didn't see this
before okay so 2626 1532
would that be the one I guess the order
would be . 615 32 that would be it right
26:15 thirty two to tango
got it okay got it i'm a G yes i'm a jew
Shaw something something was over here
where are you
those by ok goodbye
ok halfway down and war nope
what know how about who you're doing it
with me yeah well it seems like
something up in the elevator and doesn't
let me use it
okay well hey what
well that ought your oh you're fucking
dead
no i'm not i'm alive i'm alive man what
do you do
what the fuck
ok ok ok all right we're fine
oh good
well wherever you park he doesn't want
to find you
it's just that but who
hi no one's own
don't listen to my screaming voice
maybe I should answer the door
hi what
hello oh it was his decision
what so I'm not alone here at least it
seems so that was a person i'm sure
too bad he's gone now I should go look
for him yeah maybe not because they're
all the dead bodies row all the dead
bodies
think of the bodies oh hey secret is
going to come back wherever you are I
don't want to find you I'm gonna find
you in pieces and bits all over the
place
oh well it was truly unknown again
yeah i was just too late I can't hear
and talk after what it done to me i
brought you my note and hope you can
help me I'm trapped in the building
mechanics gate unexplained happenings
occurred
I can see where black shapes I feel very
unpleasant energy going through my body
I need some water please if you can take
me out of here I'll follow you
just give me a sign well I think that
was the sound of the elevator probably
working too bad for that guy
so sad oh well it was just a lad
let's get out of here
ok
it's a dick the dick tree dick
the goddamn dick oh fuck me what now
what now
got my intense brightness on got my
hater blockers
come out come out wherever you are what
he just bad bank slipped into a black
hole
oh god fuck
ok who
well you about done in there
boy you really you really had to go
mitt may I come in
I yah yah yah - 01
I guess okay bye
fuck off
hi right it's getting me with the cheap
ones now it's getting she follow me
oh it's a sign follow me come on follow
me
I were coming oh oh what was that oh
hello hi was a book
touch me who I don't know if I wanna oh
wow
or if you insist blink ok did I put you
in my pants
hi I can't touch again
ok that was a fun game glad we did the
fuck off with you
you can't hurt me yes they want to kill
you every time you see one run away
don't look at them all they wanted to
kill you that's what keeps them alive
that's what keeps them alive total
destruction killing innocent people I
looked over the side because i had a
shirt on my chair over there
nevermind this is Theory saying that
shadows are the dead people doing things
they did in their lifetime
if you get trapped in the building know
to be haunted by them I have very bad
news for you probably won't survive the
best thing to do is just stay away from
these places
oh yeah i think it's a little too late
for that besides why was this
why was this place haunted unless
there's gonna be probably some twist
ending where I'm the shadow person and
the shadows are actually real people in
stop it stop it what are you doing
hey what what what what that hey what
are you doing hey what are you doing
Oh hard you can do for her blow oh no
he's a little guy always trashcan Steve
ok I'm not bad please help me can you
see what they did to me
take me out of here I don't want to be
alone I remember leaving my bag in the
toilet there was something
hey what you need right now please go
there you're very lucky for surviving
that long
they didn't even look at me and now i am
a trash can
my god don't worry I'll help you trash
cans Steve trash can
I wouldn't i would call you trash can
Tim but Tim's already been named someone
and you got to be something the kind of
reminds me of the address can so
stickers about the best that I can do
got a long Steve go little buddy oh
you're so cute
maybe trashcan Tyler I don't know mad
and flow
oh well did you did you do this
ok this is what you do what you do try
again Steve all don't know
object or drugged girl alright thanks
Steve
where you going ok you're just keep
following me around like that you're
freakin weirdo
oh sure oh no man i got no no to do
gotta be living life being dressed in a
very interesting at all but whatever
very cool cookies okay all right Steve
have a great one have a good day good
day now you guys can Steve Steve
oh you still there thank goodness i was
almost worried
alright so what did I get in the bag
backpack only some water drink it
oh ok like look
hmm oh I didn't fuck now is some hard
water
Steve what have you done to me put it no
only my master plan
all right into my trap you activated my
trap card
trash can keep going to feel your body
you're gonna be dressed in you
ok Steve you know what fair play
can't really argue with that logic
thanks man
usually would actually understands me no
matter who fuck off in
is he gone Trask and Steve gone for
three
well shit I made it somehow not crap my
flashlight doesn't work about this
no energy left right ok I got a glow
stick
it's not much but I got it I think Steve
must have taken my shift
what a douche that steve guy locked from
behind is Steven there with my body
probably oh what the fuck was that
okay okay you gonna do it again
that's what I thought back off the boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy can't see
anything
oh boy oh boy cool
war can see anything well I can't see
anything kind of run out of batteries
already got a key
damn it I my cell ran out of batteries
when I had it on higher energy mode or
else this was planned
i'm not <percent> twenty percent
</percent> sure ok ok here we go
I need hi
Starts to pant gratuitously.
still panting.
Markimoo is scared.
Silence.
never mind.
Knocking.
huh
I don't know how he missed me oh man
that was legitimately terrifying
like legitimately terrifying thanks for
the head up heads up voice in my head
god i wish i had some batteries I
couldn't waste them all
I probably should have I probably did
damn it gives you god damn thing unless
is this is probably intentional and
bouncing back and forth whether it's
intentional or not Spencer
hi ru welcoming into your warm loving
embrace down here
probably
come out come out if you hard part is
gonna find you come out
como out my back and neck
wow that's all I can say I tends to
everything up our our pay
fuck off she's get up get out of the way
hi are you guarding that can I get
through please unmovable hopefully i can
break them with something heavy
well if they're unmovable than that be
doubtful but I got a key
checking only assume it's going to go
back to the original room
what the hell happened my mic mic got
all costs
geez that last one got me good
I got me real good all right but
hopefully there's a door here dammit god
dammit we're gonna go
ah sassafras has got to be a way we can
be a route
I can't go there so it must have been
one of the doors to the left here down
one of these corridors are so blind
okay whoops should have been this one
ok so you're Steve save you better not
follow me i'm pissed at you when i'm
your boy Steve baby or do the lewis
ok Steve whatever you do what you gotta
do
all right bye Steve hahaha
all right that was moved I'm wary of you
weary
we're almost there I think just two more
floors and we should be good huh
yep two more floors okay how do I my
flashlight back now
does actually no I still don't have
juice okay fine
glow stick it is less I don't even have
the glow stick
not working anymore well fuck you man
okay good we got flashlights batteries
all right everyone reading this please
run to the elevator something arms is
roaming through the office and even if
it has no weapons it's dangerous enough
to cause bad damage to you
please do not ignore this message get to
the exit quickly and run to their safe
building
how do you know what building is safe
why not run madly in the street
screaming your head off
that's the way that I had approached all
my problems Oh bill your jury
hello hi
I'll be with you in a second on the play
whoa hi
wow ok i was just gonna look at the pool
table for a hot second all right i'm a
common baby
what the fuck was that what happened
we you didn't move but all they moved
why what happened
I want to get in there let me throw move
your boobs are fine be that way to be
that way
anything over here
that's a silhouette to other man
the door is locked for safety reasons
please use the following code 25 times
three plus five
remember to head directly to the
elevator and then the exit door be
careful
so 80 is that the code is it actually
8000k ok that's fine that's fine that's
fine that's fine i just want to make
sure that i got everything before I bolt
on out of here by Steve by I don't
remember what I did the fuck was that
was that in the gamer in my house
oh oh yeah it was if she keeps
scratching at her bed
I was like what the hell does that know
it is
oh man because it sounded so
realistically in my life
oh hi hello kind of party is it over
what is this whoa what the hell what the
hell is this
I can cause uses going to find med
something because something is messing
with my brain again whites
why wouldn't you just go I guess to get
through here maybe
all right bye ladies and it can I get
through here
there are some meds in here pretty
please
oh ok I see what you're doing
I don't know why you needed this excuse
for those eye drops
ok what happened you happy
okay bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
fuck off with you
ok ok ok ok ok ok
I thought when I came back I would see
something standing behind me or
something but I got some meds
I don't know it doesn't seem to be there
anymore but I got him
mm-hmm
okay good i didn't want to play one last
game and come out come out wherever you
are
but at least i got my ba there's no
elevator mm that's peculiar yeah
so what do i do always there
ok I got it thank you now i can know
oh now I'm just high on drugs
Oh
AHH.(Markimoo speaks in native language)
it's behind me isn't it
hey nice ass I like your butt
what was that
well yeah oh hi how are you doing
hello friend what uh oh ok
should I shoot with high with you but oh
what I guess I logical sense says I
probably shouldn't have ran towards the
obvious bad guy but come on curiosity
got the best of me or I'll be right back
ok so now that I'm back I'm not gonna
walk towards the do's and I'm just gonna
run out of here
bye bye bye bye ok down to floor one
which means lat floor was probably means
that i'm going to get verdad here
probably not knowing how these war games
ghoul
definitely no one of these war games go
I'm almost done
good what could go wrong I'm two days
from retirement
and all right let's do this that's
exactly the same way out
we won't let you go try and stop me what
with your murder hands
I don't think you can your mind also
you're just one person now you'll die in
an agonizing pain in just one agonizing
pain
come on now i can take at least seven
agonizing pains
no okay that door doesn't work and
there's something thumping on the run
today
you don't have to tell me twice bye-bye
this part of the club and I don't have
brown
we're okay wait a minute just hearing
center is there something else
jeez with the chair moved I'm alrighty
then
thank you for sticking to our advices
please leave the building and head to
the nearest safe place gas station etc
make sure to call this number next next
k 660 295 oh fuck come on
okay got it all right boink I got a
number gonna go
I asked apid I was one of the luckys
people this day
not many made it to the exit alive
therefore i will never forget what
horror I went through
only because of that no one will ever
know what really happened there
uh-huh
I that's the end ok so that was really
good
I like that I like that a lot it scared
me a whole bunch it had moments where he
broke the atmosphere and it didn't seem
all that scary and admittedly it was a
little repetitive because the way I was
exactly the same but it did a lot
it did a lot with very little and I like
it anyway he only started in may of this
year so you know not not that long
making it but still it was pretty then
good for being something that was
legitimately scary and rough around the
edges but it's totally fine and for a
free game not that better was a free i
can remember i think it was free but
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you developer for
making this game
I'm going to check on the main menu
because i believe there was something
that said secrets but I don't know if I
found all the secrets so i don't know if
that's going to help and
secrets collect all secrets are unlocked
interesting facts and supervision the
game ok so i don't have that
yeah I don't have it I didn't get all of
my mr. for you so sorry about that but
maybe if you play the game you can
unlock the secrets for yourself i'll put
a link in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
be sure to check out all the other scare
games that I played there's a huge
playlist up a link in the description
over 200 videos of their games and stuff
like that so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
BUH-BYE!
*Music*